there is so much happening with
Spider-Man lately and a lot about to
come up and not just in the MCU
Spider-Man knowing home was obviously a
massive success but so was Spider-Man
across the spiderverse both films left a
lot of Spider-Man fans wanting even more
and the great news is a lot more is
about to come when it comes to
Spider-Man and we are talking MCU Sony
spiderverse and of course the animated
spiderverse as well all of which could
be connected and all could appear in one
Universe an Avengers Secret Wars but
today we have talks of a new director
for Spider-Man 4 with Tom Holland there
are rumors going around right now that
Andrew Garfield could be returning as
well possibly for The Amazing Spider-Man
3 and of course as most people know we
are getting a Spider-Man beyond the
spiderverse the third film in the
animated spiderverse Trilogy so a lot to
dissect today let's go ahead and start
breaking it down but if you're new be
sure to subscribe to the channel so you
don't miss out on any of the latest
Spider-Man and Marvel news and if you
subscribe and leave a comment down below
you're automatically entered in our
giveaway for a chance to win a PS5 an
Xbox series X some Marvel Legends items
and some DC items as well the winner
gets to pick one item and we pick one
winner at the end of each month so
starting off with Spider-Man 4 we heard
that John Watts was done after
Spider-Man no way home he directed the
Spider-Man homecoming Trilogy gave us
some amazing movies and he brought
together Toby Maguire Spider-Man Andrew
Garfield Spider-Man and of course Tom
Holland and Spider-Man no way home he
was supposed to go on after this to
direct the Fantastic 4 film in fact
Marvel Studios had already made an
official announcement about it however
after Spider-Man Noy home came out he
announced that he was going to be taking
a break from Superhero films after
directing the entire Trilogy and after
dealing with all of the leaks for
Spider-Man no way home he decided he
needed a break which is perfectly
understandable so he was supposedly done
however we have a report today that
states there is still a chance that he
could return and direct Spider-Man 4 but
we also have a report of a possible new
director for the next Spider-Man
installment in a report from Insider
Daniel rpk he states that Marvel Studios
is reportedly searching for a new
director for Spider-Man 4 Drew Goddard
is one of Kevin Fig's and Sony's choices
to direct Spider-Man 4 there is still a
chance for John Watts to return to
direct now first things first it would
make sense that Marvel and Sony would
want John Watts to return the three
Spider-Man films that he directed were
massive successes with homecoming
earning over 880 million worldwide
Spider-Man far from home being the first
Spider-Man film to gross over a billion
dollar making 1.1 billion worldwide and
then of course Spider-Man no way home
coming in with a whopping
1.9 billion the films of course were
massive successes so it would make sense
that Marvel and Sony would of course be
open to John Watts returning to direct
these films and it's been a while it's
been a few years since Spider-Man know
way home perhaps John Watts has taken a
necessary break that he's needed and is
ready to return in which case like we
said obviously Marvel and Sony would be
open to that but Drew Goddard is also a
great choice as he has been attached to
many wonderful and outstanding projects
including being an executive producer
for the Netflix Daredevil series and the
Defenders as well he was also attached
to Lost and the Martian with Matt Damon
which was a phenomenal movie and many
more movies and shows so he would be an
excellent pick as well plus he has
worked on Marvel projects before with
Daredevil and the Defenders and now he
could play in the MCU which I think
would be a dream come true for anyone
and what's really interesting about that
is and this could be an indicator of
what we could see for Spider-Man 4
Daredevil is now a part of the Marvel
Cinematic Universe and we've heard
rumors for a while that Daredevil is
going to appear in one of the Spider-Man
upcoming movies this could be why Marvel
Studios is eyeing Drew Goddard because
they want Daredevil and Spider-Man 4 and
since he worked on the Daredevil Series
this might be perfect because he's
literally worked with Charlie Cox before
plus not to mention Spider-Man no way
home did set up Matt Murdoch SL
Daredevil to come in they literally
introduced him in the film now we didn't
see Daredevil we saw Matt Murdoch but
still of course he is Daredevil and it's
very clear at this point by him catching
the brick that he is fighting crime plus
of course we saw him in She-Hulk as well
so we know he's also set up to return in
the Echo series and again of course in
his own series and hopefully he does
make his way over into a movie with
Spider-Man I think everybody would
really like that but go ahead and let me
know your thoughts about Drew Goddard
possibly being the director for
Spider-Man 4 would you like that or
would you like John Watts to return now
we mentioned that there was a rumor
going around that Andrew Garfield could
possibly be returning for a third film
of The Amazing Spider-Man and I'll
explain where this is coming from Sony
did a special screening of Spider-Man
across the spiderverse in London I
believe yesterday I believe it was last
night although it could have been this
morning and Andrew Garfield showed
showed up and he appeared on stage with
executive producer for Spider-Man and
Sony Amy Pascal and he moderated the Q&A
session after the movie and it was
pretty cool he called Spider-Man across
the spiderverse a masterpiece check it
out
here
yo guys this is so great I'm so happy to
and honored to be here this is the first
time I've ever done a Q&A with any
humans let alone humans that I love
after the movie that you guys just saw
which I think we can all agree is kind
of a masterpiece
of
Animation but also a masterpiece of just
pure Cinema um without any separation so
after this happened of course a lot of
people were talking about Andrew
Garfield being with Sony again and
working close to them and after
Spider-Man no way home came out and it
was a massive success a lot of insiders
said that Sony is definitely considering
working with Andrew Garfield again they
want him back and considering how much
fans loved him in no way home they were
considering doing a The Amazing
Spider-Man number three keep in mind
this was not confirmed in any way but of
course it would definitely make sense
that Sony would want to capitalize on
that and Andrew Garfield said that he is
open to return so did Toby Maguire in
which we also heard that they might be
considering doing a Spider-Man 4 with
Toby Maguire as well here's the thing
keep in mind Sony is now building their
liveaction spiderverse and it's going to
be a Multiverse just like the MCU is
doing but it's going to only consist of
Spider-Man characters maybe a few other
non-related Spider-Man characters thrown
in there but mostly it's Spider-Man and
the spiderverse and they're believed to
be building up to a massive Multiverse
movie like Secret Wars is going to be
but it's going to be a spider gedon so
although we have heard rumors for a
while now that the Amazing Spider-Man 3
could happen they also could simply be
planning on Andrew Garfield one
appearing in Avengers Secret Wars which
I do believe is going to happen we know
Toby Maguire is going to appear in
Avengers Secret Wars it would make sense
for Andrew Garfield 2o as well
especially after Spider-Man no way home
but two they could also be preparing for
Andrew garfi field to appear in their
liveaction spiderverse now this would
obviously be the same character that he
has played in the other Amazing
Spider-Man films I think it's totally
possible and probable that he shows up
in secret Wars and in a big spider-verse
film for Sony could the rumors be true
and Sony be making the Amazing
Spider-Man 3 of course they could be
true but unfortunately nothing is
confirmed at the time it's just a rumor
going around right now since this video
has come out however I will say expect
Andrew Garfield to return in some
capacity I believe he'll be back but the
future of Spider-Man is looking insanely
bright right now there's even been talks
recently from a lot of insiders stating
that Tom Holland Spider-Man might jump
over to the Sony spider Universe
relatively soon to take on Venom and one
thing is for sure we should expect to
see Tom Holland Toby Maguire and Andrew
Garfield together on screen at one point
in time probably in secret Wars
reuniting and fighting together again
which will be absolutely epic but go
ahead and let us know all of your
thoughts about all of this news in the
comments down below do you think Drew GD
would be a good director or do you want
John Watts back and do you want a The
Amazing Spider-Man 3 with Andrew
Garfield let us know your thoughts down
below don't forget to like the video and
subscribe you can find us on Instagram
and Twitter and as always thank you all
so much for watching woof woof